hello everybody my name is nya and i'm
the black female engineer and today
we are going to be discussing my coding
bootcamp experience
which is really going to also be a
flatiron school
coding bootcamp review as well so
getting right to it i started my coding
bootcamp june
29th last week of june i started the
last week of june
and the first thing that struck me were
the class sizes
before because i'm pretty sure you know
this is going to
to really make sure that we're all on
the same page
because of this whole parallelogram i
was on line
but that doesn't mean in the selection
of you know what kind of course are you
doing that doesn't mean that i chose an
online
course i didn't choose that program this
was still the in person
but because of everything going on it
was through
zoom so live sessions through zoom
rather than if you chose an
online bootcamp it would be non-live
sessions um
it would be more self-paced and so this
was really as
in person as it can be without being in
person
so first thing that struck me were the
class sizes
they were smaller than i
envisioned i don't know if that is
typical
for flat iron school or anything like
that oh yeah i don't think i mentioned
that
i went to flatiron school that is the
coding bootcamp i went to
for four months and it was specifically
the software engineering
uh coding bootcamp or the software
engineering course
so i don't know if 15 people
was typical was a typical class size for
them it might have or might not have
because
maybe people decided to hold off on
going into coding boot camp because
of this whole panoramic going on but you
know what a year later
you should have just joined the boot
camp because look at where we are
but um it's not too late like please if
you want to like do something like just
go out do it do it now because you don't
know how long things are going to last
but yeah so it's 15 people and now the
second thing
that really struck me was
the two women in the entire cohort
one of them being myself and so i was
kind of expecting this like i do
know that you know the tech world
and software engineering really in
particular
is very male dominated i do understand
that
but i don't know y'all like still
being in there and still seeing just
like the one
female face i was still kind of like
come on
like let's do better than this but you
know what on the bright side you know
that was
an instant you know homie an instant
best friend for the cohort so you know
it
things work out you make the best of any
situation but it was
um that is something that did strike me
i
was the youngest person in the boot camp
i'm 22 years old and i'd want to say the
average age i wasn't
you know too skewed but i'd say the
average age was about
29 between 29 and 31
yeah like in between there um like it
seems like you know everyone i was with
you know had full-blown
husbands and wives and children they had
full-blown you know lives of people to
be accountable for and meanwhile i'm
over here
pressing play for the zoom in my you
know onesie
and everything so you know that was
something that
did make me nervous because i was just
like geez like
how are they going to look at me like
they're going to not take me seriously
they're not going to
you know think i'm skilled enough or
they think you know
what overwhelmingly like that was
honestly all just like a moot point like
we were
all in here for the same reason we were
trying to switch from one
industry to the next and we were all
make wanting to make sure that we got
through it so
for the most part like that really
wasn't a you know
a big factor um and it shouldn't be a
deterrent to anyone who
may feel like an outlier um because
at the end of the day like y'all we're
all just trying to make sure
we succeed and get through this and that
very much was the vibe
that's another thing i felt going
in like i thought that it would be like
the hunger games like the whole
vibe was like fight to the finish like
move
out of my way each person for themselves
but it was not like that at
all like even like like eight days in i
was over here having um
just like a one-on-one zoom session with
one of my classmates
who was helping me get through um one of
the topics that i was struggling on
and this was at like 8 p.m we spoke for
like an hour and a half and everything
like
it was very much a thing of we
are all to make sure to get through this
now that being said
you know only half of us got
through it um we only half of us made it
to our
original you know graduation date and
all
but you know what coding bootcamp is
hard and people
you know lean off of it or you know
decide to take a step back or anything
for
any number of reasons it doesn't always
mean that you know they weren't
you know they couldn't do it or anything
like they're not smart enough they're
not no it's none of that
just a lot of people may realize that
this isn't the path for them
and just continue searching elsewhere or
that you know
the timing just was off so it could be
for a number of reasons but i just want
to
make it clear or just
provide that insight of the people you
do start with
they likely will not be the same people
you end up with
it's very sad and disappointing but
that's just
the vastness where we're at with that so
now getting into what a day looked like
at flattering school so we started off
at around 9 00 a.m
um with a morning stand up so some
companies have this some
schools have this but you wake up
you know 9 a.m for us it was you know
zoom we open our zoom
and it started with and first of all
like an update of how everyone's feeling
how everyone's doing just like catching
up and then it went into trying to
gauge how the students felt about
certain topics and chapters and
content and the teachers really wrapping
their
lessons around that so that's something
i absolutely
loved with flatiron school the teachers
really wrapped their lessons plan
their lesson plans around what the
students
were wanting to see more of wanting to
get more practice in and everything
they of course had their own you know on
this day we're going to learn ruby and
then we're going to learn
you know rails and then we're going to
learn javascript and things like that
but it also was okay here is what we
have planned and this is you know
what the schedule is going to be but if
a student was like hey i'd actually also
really like
a repeat of yesterday's lesson or um
be able to talk about this or this or
this even if it wasn't even
in like the syllabus like hey i really
want to learn you know
node or something then like a teacher
would make sure to provide something for
that student
to really make sure they're getting out
of it what they
want to see because yeah that's 18
like thousand dollars you know anywhere
from coding bootcamps like
12 to 20 000 so like and some more
you know so and then some less but you
really want to make sure
you are getting out of it everything you
can and as a student really making sure
that you're speaking up and saying
look like you need to go through this
again because i don't know why but my
brain is not sticking to it so please
just like
give me another lesson of this and they
were so gracious
constantly and just fantastic in that
regard so
that is what's kind of really um
encompassed
it was hey how are you how's everyone
feeling and then
how are we going to get through this day
what are
our lessons going to be looking like and
then what are things that some people
may specifically want and let's see how
we can
integrate that into the day as well then
p.m was really when we were like okay
like laptops
off because stand down would be between
like 5
15 and like 5 40. and stand down was
really kind of like a repeat
of the morning stand up but instead
really being able to like unwind and
like wind down
so what did you learn today um
what's something you're like thankful
for what's something you'd like want to
just like talk about or like in just
like in your lives
um and great you all did a great job and
we'll see you all tomorrow this really
allowed people to like have a time where
they were like you know at this time i
end and like laptops off because what
um sometimes happens is if classes or
jobs or any of the sorts if they don't
do that and don't have an actual like
stand down
then students or you know employees
just keep going and going and going
because they weren't
given like permission to be done and so
this kind of like
gave people permission to be done so
that is really when the day ended and as
for the day itself it was a mix between
teacher led lessons where the teacher
would
share their screen and you know you
would have your
you know code pulled up and be coding
along or taking notes depending on
what the lesson really called for it was
a mix between that
and having more of like
self-instruction based on like the
chapters you're on and things like that
i say chapters just because i feel like
that's something all of us you know
recognize but um what it really was was
a portal where we could see all the
things that we're supposed to
know by which by which point in time and
once you learn this you should learn
this and it would have tutorials and you
know actual lessons and like
like chapters like like a book and so
it would be a mix between switching back
and forth between the teachers lessons
and going to your like book and um
going through that cycle and that
process as well so a mix of those two
getting you to that you know stand down
mark
so that was day to day now if you look
at more like
bigger picture so every third week we
had a project we had to do
the project was just you know building
some type of app web app
or an actual mobile app building some
kind of app
with some kind of either technology or
framework or something that had been
taught
during the last you know three weeks so
flaring school we had modules um modules
like
chapters think of them just as chapters
where every three weeks was a new module
so we had five modules
in total and it went from yeah like
module one being like ruby then module
two being rails then module three being
like
javascript uh four being react
and then module five was more
self-guided module where you build your
own app
and it's something that you know
you is a culmination of the last you
know
four months of the program so that is
how things are split up and so
like i said every three weeks was a
different module and at the end of every
three weeks
we were to build a an app of some kind
but then
every two weeks like every second
week of a module was like kind of like
exam time
where you kind of have to like
[Music]
pass the test pass a test um i say test
slightly they
if someone's watching this from flatiron
school you know that you know
they didn't like the word test it's not
a test but it's a test like let's call
you know a spade a spade that's
you know let's see what it is it was a
test and
whether or not you passed it determined
on if you could move on to the next
module or if you were quote held back
held back being that
you had the option of retaking the
module but if you retook the module
you were held back you were now on the
delay of like
six weeks um because you were waiting
for the next cohort
to come in and now you're taking
this new module with the new cohort it's
very confusing
um but basically yeah you're held back
just like how you know if it's like
ninth grade and you weren't able to pass
the class and so now you're held back
but you need to wait the summer
um for you to join the next incoming
class
to join them and now you're part of
their
you know graduating year and everything
and now that those are your people
same exact um thing with flatiron you
had to wait
six weeks and join a new class but yeah
every two weeks you had a test every
three weeks you had a project
so overall the things i appreciated most
of flatiron i mentioned this before
was the focus on the students the focus
on
what do the students like and don't like
and what are they struggling on what do
they need more assistance with
uh let's make sure we structure our
day and our week based on assisting that
or even not even struggling but what do
they want to learn like okay this person
wants to learn
material ui like okay let's put in
slots for learning just that and let's
make sure a teacher is able to teach
just that for the people who are
interested in that and so just because
something wasn't like on the like
you know syllabus and everything didn't
mean that we couldn't learn it
that being said i don't know if that is
the way for every single
flatiron um like location and school and
everything
i was part of the denver school i don't
know if
that is the same case for everybody but
that's how it was for me
something i do wish flatiron
incorporated more i'd say were would be
algorithms
um there really wasn't a ton of time to
incorporate algorithms into the
structure because yeah it's a very fast
turnaround
um with this boot camp and everything
and so sometimes he just didn't have
time
but you know if it was a perfect world i
do wish there had been
a module just dedicated to algorithms so
that
you know when you get to the
interviewing process and things like
that you felt more prepared rather than
you were on your own we were never on
our own
school i'll say that but yeah feeling
like you are now doing this by yourself
and having to learn this other side of
things just so you can get a
job even though you may not even work
with
specific algo stuff and things like that
so that is something i do um
wish in a perfect world had been
incorporated but in general i
loved flatiron school i would if the
tuition was double i still would have
paid it
knowing what i know now and i ended up
getting a job
just three weeks after graduation my
first offer was just a few hours after
graduation
and i ended up getting a job just
signing on the job i really really
wanted three weeks after graduation so
they prepared me very
well i'd say and i'm very grateful so
there we go
there is my coding bootcamp experience
and my overall review on flat iron
school so
please subscribe if you like this video
i'm really trying to get to 100
subscribers
so please help me out there and there is
going to be a video coming to you
soon so now thank you bye y'all